irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
irak nous sommes nous a accueilli par
une véritable tempête de sable
en descendant sur bagdad la grande route
irakienne traverse les impressionnantes
installations pétrolifère de kirkouk
kirkouk qui fit tant parler d'elle
pendant la guerre kirkouk
mam du budget irakien kirkouk où un
soleil d'enfer écrase de ses rayons une
terre rouge gorgé de pétrole
oui c'est la fraîcheur des montagnes
kurde et tout au bout du monde valais la
surprise à l'énorme chantier dirigé par
une société française en plein coeur de
secouriste en rude et sauvage
malgré la rupture de ses relations
diplomatiques avec la france plusieurs
centaines d'ingénieurs et le technicien
français construisent le plus grand
barrage d'irak
ado cannes
les villages ont presque tous cet aspect
maisons de torchis rarement de pierre
vis à un peu archaïque
chacun vaque à ses occupations début de
l'époque biblique
il semble que rien n'ait bougé depuis ce
sens là
parmi les tribus du nord il existe la
très curieuse secte des liaisons ou
adorateurs du diable
il professe qu'une fois aux origines
indéterminées les sectateurs cet écran
religion se rencontrent également dans
le nord de la civi en fait ils n'adore
pas le diable non tu le respectes c'est
évidemment beaucoup mieux poudres en
estimant les colères du diable très
dangereuse est beaucoup plus dangereuse
que celle de vieux ils en furent 500 de
prévenance père et fils et soleil sous
les angles les yézidis réunissent au
village de balle chic pour fêter
ensemble la mort de leurs grands
prophètes et cette fête d'un lieu le
grandes réjouissances populaires bon les
champs dans
oui
et
maintenant mettons le cap sur l'iran ken
macha première grande ville de lac ps
voitures à cheval qui évoque les troïka
de la russie cette joute caniveau
remplaçants traîtreusement nos bons
trottoirs les bains où m que les
iraniens font cuire sur un galet
laquelle des centaines de kilomètres au
nord la caspienne dans le niveau est à
26 mètres au dessous du niveau normal
des océans
son climat favorise la culture du riz
base de l'alimentation iranien dictée
boisson nationale
c'est dire l'importance économique de
cette région et sa richesse
en remontant vers l'ouest que nous
traversons laser bike autres chantres
essentiel de l'économie iranienne pour
suppléer aux précipitations
atmosphériques insuffisantes les
peuplades d'origine turque de cette
région ont établi d'ingénieuses et
archaïque puis à balancier que deux
ouvriers font inlassablement fonctionner
jouer nuit en période de sécheresse
il arrache outre après août l'eau
précieuse qui se cache dans le sol
puis le long la caspienne sur le sable
noir et dur qui bordent interminablement
son image se tiennent les pêcheurs
d'esturgeons l'esturgeon le poisson
caviar savez vous connaissez la
caspienne est en effet la mer par
excellence de l'esturgeon tout le long
de son littoral russe ou iranien des
centaines de pêcheries sont installés
construction de bois sur pilotis où
vivent les pêcheurs
très tôt dans le matin bien avant que le
soleil ne se lève les équipes de pêche
cousteau l'âge leur barque à fond plat
qu'il dirige soit à la rame soit à la
voile il pique droit au large
remontant le fil et à poste fixe qu'ils
ont entendu ou les bus de la saison est
fixé à l'aide de croupir de bois sur le
fond sableux le filet s'étale sur 15
cents ou 2000 mètres
arrivé à son extrémité l'équipage
commencent à se aller dessus quand un
esturgeon et dans l'émail le hisse à
bord le rejette si c'est un mâle de la
chance s'il est trop jeune ou la somme
si c'est une femelle
en effet pour avoir du caviar de
première qualité il ne faut pas que la
femelle meurent avant le prélèvement de
ses poches seul le corps pantelant du
poisson passe alors à la bascule puisse
pour la voir puis-je frigorifique tandis
que les oeufs recueillis dans un bac
sont passés au tamis par une main expekt
il faut en effet à petits coups séparer
les eaux de leur enveloppe ajouter une
dose de sel variable suivant que ce
caviar être destiné à l'amérique ou à
l'europe enfin re tamisée pour obtenir
une pureté parfaite et le chef de la
pêcherie c'est à lui que cela revient
rempli à grands coups de louche de
volumineuses boîtes d'un kilo qui
partiront soigneusement réfléchir et sur
votre table peut-être qui sait
en route vers le plateau iranienne
soleil poussière chaleur et les
rencontres aux éternels des tribus
transhumants de l'antique ps le débat
vendent le plus haut sommet d'hier en
volcan éteint à 5670 m avec ces plaques
neigeuse sur ces pentes pendant l'été
les familles de berger élève des moutons
une fois par jour hommes et femmes pour
7 à la traite des brebis dans dimanche
auront le cuivre ont littéralement
culotté
le lait de ses brebis sert à faire
yourte iranien le mas stes
incomparablement savoureux paraît-il il
est consommé nature ou mélangé à
quelques plats du cru
mais pour arriver au plateau la route et
l'on est bien souvent scabreuse passage
de cours d'eau par endroits la neige
déjà fondante paysages impressionnants
intégralement géologiques que celui de
cette région terre faite de roches
d'éclabousser ou la route se fraie un
passage ou de remblais de tunnels de
glissades dans des trois ouvertures
et de ce no man's land de nature
primitive
nous retombons brutalement en plein
coeur de l'agitation or qu'est ce cri de
la capitale du pakistan occidental
karachi
on circule à gauche dans les rues
l'angleterre est passée par là cette
circulation y est impeccablement ordonné
ce qui est tout à fait extraordinaire
pour leur bien ou même pour le proche
orient
e
d'un trottoir regardez filmé au
téléobjectif de musulmanes voilées de la
tête aux pieds
le népal est proche maintenant de
karachi new delhi de new delhi à patna
de patna à la frontière une piste
poussiéreuse un chemin de fer à voie
étroite disputent le passage à la forêt
il vient la semaine prochaine nous
aborderons ensemble le népal
il un caillou vous avons conseillé
voyage son passeport cette émission a
été réalisée avec un film de maurice
braud et christian potier montage on est
garé script jacques nouard sont alain
gautier illustration sonore dominic
palladini réalisation au sol ange péters